ever since I read the book in Praise of
Shadows I've always had this image of
Japan but when I visited for the first
time in August it wasn't quite what I
expected even the places that jinichiro
tanaki beautifully describes in his book
it was almost impossible to experience
them as they were intended as an
architect trying to identify my own
philosophy on design I felt myself
desperately trying to cling to this idea
of this mysterious place but every time
I tried to reach it it kept getting away
from me was I too late does my idea of
Japan still
exist I decided to travel to a place
where space sound and time are perceived
in a completely different way a place
where people Embrace and craft the
Shadows
Japan a portion of this video sponsored
by
Fiverr
[Music]
this is the sayama pond about an hour
and a half away from the heart of Osaka
and we came here hoping to experience
something different it's Japan's oldest
Reservoir dating back to the 7th century
and for Generations the water from this
Pond nurtured the land and sustained the
communities in the shintoist OR animous
Traditions that's rooted in Japanese
culture places like this aren't just
resources or landscapes they're The
Dwelling Places of the spirits who
protect the land and you can feel this
reverence for nature at the saiki Museum
which was designed by the pritsker prize
winning architect tadal Ando the museum
covers the history of Japan's flood
control measures and irrigation systems
but it's a lot more than
that standing there I felt small like I
was being swallowed by the presence of
something
Grand simple geometries create a sense
of visual Harmony and all of this made
me
pause there's rituals twice every hour
for 5 minutes there's a waterfall that
you can walk under a little further down
there's a circular Courtyard and walking
up the length of the ramp as you circle
around the geometry it slows down your
pace before entering the museum just
like a medieval Labyrinth which
purposely slows you down by taking the
long route when you finally enter the
museum you're faced with a Monumental
structure it's a from the old Bank of
the pond and as you walk down this long
wrap you can almost feel the history
embedded in each layer of the sediment
this determines the height of the
building meaning the building is the
exact depth of the pond creating this
symbolic connection then there's the
natural light which is celebrated and
made more beautiful by putting it
against concrete and creating a deep
Shadow around
it when junichiro tanaki describes the
shadows in traditional Japanese
Aesthetics he's talking about
this the layered glow of the shoi screen
the subtle soft daylight that enters
through the Deep Eaves of a Japanese
roof but tadal Ando he takes this into a
whole new
[Music]
dimension T wo was actually a
self-trained architect and in 1964 when
he was just 24 years old he traveled to
Rome and visited the
pantheon there he found a very different
kind of light than the one that's
praised in his home country the single
Central cutout in the pantheon created
this dramatic gesture it's dark and in
certain moments it cuts through the
space Like a Knife apparently this was
the moment he decided to become an
[Music]
architect throughout our trip we visit
visited a lot of Tad Ono's buildings and
I think what's really unique about his
architecture is how he merges the Nuance
Japanese Shadow with a bold almost
theatrical kind of light he said the
light becomes glorious only when it's
lit against the background of the
deepest darkness in a spaces even the
gentlest most restrained daylight
becomes a spectacle and it sculpts the
concrete with a deep Shadow and for
brief moments of the day a slit of light
comes in that breaks the concrete
surface and intensifying the spatial
depth and in these moments time becomes
tangible but the more time I spent in
Japan I realized this obsession with
shadows it's not just about what we see
or even understand with
logic this is St Mary's cathedral in
Tokyo by Kenzo tan it reminds me of
something that was made not by humans
but crafted by the immense force of
nature sitting here I felt heavy and
weightless at the same time there's a
concept in Japanese Aesthetics yugan it
comes from Zen Buddhism and speaks to a
profound mysterious sense of beauty of
the universe and also the sad beauty of
human suffering at St Mary's Cathedral
there's an atmosphere that's both awe
inspiring and enigmatic it really really
does give you the sense of an unknowable
Beauty that's profound but remains just
beyond the grasp of full comprehension
but actually this feeling might just be
a deliberate design Choice by Kenzo tan
trying to avoid any obvious symbolism at
the Cathedral if you look at the
building from an aerial view you will
see that the window openings form a
cross but unless you can fly most of us
will never see the building from this
angle you can only feel the the presence
of the Cross as two lines of light
Illuminating the space he also blurs the
line between walls and ceiling creating
a single continuous form that challenges
our sense of boundaries this also
creates a very strong perspective and
depth making the cathedral seem grander
than it really is the textures add to
this illusion and it reminds you of
something that you would find in
nature what was he
saying
what uh are you
okay that's Miho from our sponsor fivr
ah hi miho hi we hired Miho and Ido from
Fiverr to translate and dub this video
in Japanese Fiverr is a great platform
where you can find professionals from
all over the world from graphic design
video production marketing and creative
writing it's virtually impossible
posible not to find what you're looking
for in such a great community and Fiverr
gives you all the tools to get the job
done even if you have a really small
budget in fact it was super easy to work
with Miho and Ito and the whole process
was super fast so whatever creative
project you have in your mind you can
get it done with Fiverr visit fiverr.com
to get a 10% discount on your next
project thanks again Miho and IO for
helping us out
[Music]
zembo is a Meditation Retreat in aaji
Island designed by shikar Ruban and here
I experienced some of these ideas in a
totally different light it's a 100 met
long Timber structure built with a
combination of pine Cedar and other
Timbers from Japan in fact the whole
place had this lingering scent of
Japanese Cedar it's respectfully
integrated into the landscape aligning
with the Mountain Ridge rather than
sitting above it and almost hovering
over the forest minimizing its footprint
and it creates this delicate balance of
Nature and man-made this was my very
first Meditation Retreat but I have
practiced meditation on and off for a
lot of years but this was a whole new
experience from my practice at home it
wasn't just about clearing the mind it
was about deepening the sensory
experienced and my connection to Nature
Zen Buddhism is about a direct
experiential understanding through
meditation and mindfulness and being
present it's about a connection with the
ordinary parts of life and with nature
so I think a lot of Japanese designs are
simple and understated but it highlights
the things around us in Tad Ando spaces
he highlights the trees or the sky or
the People by Framing them and turning
them into to artworks here we highlight
nature using a simple flat roof and
creating this steady repetitive rhythm
with wood beams and columns the central
platform steps up stepping back from the
glass railing so when you're sitting on
the platform you get an almost
unobstructed view of the Horizon sitting
here it's kind of a sensory delight and
it made the meditation practice almost
effortless I could feel the breeze the
rustling of the leaves the subtle scent
of the forest the rhythmic coming of the
Circas something that I noticed was how
Japanese people were so light on their
feet even the guys they walked like this
landing on the balls of their feet cuz
in a wood building like this and also
probably in traditional Japanese
buildings if you're walking with the
heels first you can hear that sound in
the entire higher
space and you feel extremely
intrusive and this was actually a bit of
a challenge for me which is funny cuz my
favorite part of the whole experience
was actually the walking meditation as I
focus on just walking I was surprised to
feel the texture of the wood on my feet
and the subtle temperature differences
in the parts of the floor that were
shaded by The Columns but it's not just
the meditation the whole building is
essentially one long linear procession
and as you walk down the long halls or
the meditation platform the rhythm of
the structure helps you slow down your
pace there's a Japanese concept ma it's
the space between elements the time
between the beginning and the end it's
the Gap the space or the pause but Ma is
not simply an absence but an active
presence that shapes our experience
experiences and this concept captures my
experience here at zambo although I came
here to pause my experience was actually
quite
[Music]
full we visited a lot of different
places in Japan but there was one place
that was a testament to some of these
Concepts we're talking about but the
trip to this building was not easy it
was about 3 and 1/2 hours Transit from
aaji Island to this small Port Town and
another ferry to the island all of this
for this one building it started raining
on our Ferry and it continued to rain as
we made our way up the hill walking up
we could see the beautiful Lush
landscape and a change in the air once
we reached the site there was this
winding path through different
Landscapes and soundscapes with a cool
Ocean Breeze coming from the left at the
end of the path is a large monolithic
concrete Dome sitting in the
landscape
and when I entered the first thing I
noticed is the silence and then a
strange sound echoing in the space then
you see that everyone is kind of looking
at the floor either standing around or
sitting down at first I thought the pool
of water on the ground was from the rain
and some of it definitely was cuz there
were two large openings open to the air
but when I look closer I noticed that
the small droplets of water were moving
trick Ling down ever so slowly combining
with other droplets into these tiny
holes in the concrete making a sound
like
this I along with dozens of other people
sat there for hours and slowly you start
to notice more and more details I
noticed that the space seemed to capture
sound even from a distance for example I
noticed that a crow flew overhead making
this but you could hear the sound Echo
inside the Dome there were two large
openings one facing the forest and one
facing the sky which allowed the wind to
funnel through when the wind blew the
leaves would rustle I could feel the
wind brushing against me and a piece of
string which were hung on either holes
would float ever so gently in the
[Music]
Wind
there's a fundamental difference between
Western philosophy and Eastern
philosophy Western culture is rooted in
the enlightenment's ideals of reason and
Clarity and light has become a symbol of
knowledge and progress so we don't like
Shadows we try to get as much light as
possible but Eastern culture is rooted
in Shinto and Buddhist philosophies
where they appreciate the ephemeral and
the subtle and more than any other
Eastern country I think Japan has been
able to preserve and refine this into
their design philosophy which is why
when you visit a lot of their cities
you'll see this beautiful seamless
connection between the old and the new
the problem is in today's visual culture
driven by the algorithm there's not a
lot of room for NU on we want the quick
reward we want the money shots we want
the Maximum Impact in the shortest
amount of time possible and I guess
that's also kind of the irony of this
video I'm describing verbally and
Visually what you should be experiencing
with your whole body over an extended
period of time so I would still highly
recommend you check out some of these
places for yourself if you want the full
travel itary of the buildings that we
visited and how we got there we've
created a PDF that you can download and
I'll link it in the description my
challenge to you describe a place that's
stuck in your mind for whatever reason
try to be as detailed as possible what
did you see what did you hear what did
you feel you can leave your responses in
the
[Music]
comments